au canada il ya une règle non écrite qui
dit qu'on doit donner en 15 et 20% de
pourvoir à la fin d'un repas
mais dans les faits la somme qu'on
ajoute à l'addition varie légèrement
d'une ville à l'autre
savez vous où habitent les clients les
plus généreux au pays
à vancouver les clients donnent en
moyenne 100 ennemis pour ça ça fait 2
les clients les plus généreux au pays
vient ensuite ottawa où on donne environ
15,7 pour cent à montréal toronto
halifax et calgary
on donne généralement légèrement moins
que la norme de 15% et c'est en
saskatchewan et au nouveau-brunswick que
l'on donne le moins avec en moyenne 13,7
pour cent
maintenant la question qui est au coeur
du débat à qui dois aller l'argent
seulement aux serveurs ou partagé à
l'ensemble du personnel en cuisine
il faut savoir que le partage des
pourboires ça existe déjà dans plusieurs
restaurants au canada
la différence c'est la personne qui
décide parce que ce sont les serveurs
qui doivent décider où les patrons qui
doivent décider de partager les
pourboires au québec malgré la pression
des restaurateurs le gouvernement a
tranché ce sont aux serveurs de décider
ou non de partager leurs pourboires en
ontario depuis 2016 le patron d'un
restaurant peut décider seul de partager
le pourboire à l'ensemble du personnel
en cuisine faut savoir c'est que le
travail en cuisine c'est pas payant
c'est difficile de recruter du personnel
et les restaurateurs disent ne pas avoir
la marge de profil nécessaire pour
augmenter les salaires en théorie
l'objectif du partage des pourboires
c'est donc de réduire les inégalités
salariales entre les serveurs et les
cuisiniers par exemple pour faire face à
la pénurie de main d'oeuvre
mais en pratique des restaurateurs de
l'ontario qui sont soupçonnés d'avoir
érigé dans les pourboires des serveurs
pour compenser la hausse du salaire
minimum du personnel en cuisine qui est
passé à 14 dollars de l'heure depuis le
début de l'année la faire tellement fait
de remous que la première ministre
ontarienne a elle même décidé
d'intervenir et la commission des
relations de travail de l'ontario mènent
actuellement une enquête
[Musique]